the European Union finances a wide range
of projects aimed at improving our
living environment unfortunately people
sometimes try to misuse these funds we
at Ola the European anti-fraud office
are here to track them down starting the
day with a tip-off about a suspected
fraud EU funds have been sent to build a
hospital in one of Europe's poorer
regions but where is the hospital now
after the port to investigate an illegal
cigarettes shipment with the customs
authorities we estimate a 10 billion
euros a year the loss caused by illicit
trade in cigarettes this farm received
funding for educational activities for
children but we suspect the funds were
diverted for personal use it's time to
go and check on the spot one final
destination on the list today we're
flying to Africa we are coordinating an
investigation on EU development aid for
the coffee and cocoa sectors local
authorities suspect several million
euros of them is used when the budget of
the European Union is threatened by
fraudsters the victims are the European
citizens themselves and the entire
European project
the European anti-fraud eyes detect
investigate protect